và tài dù dê việc trẻ lưu cao bốn châu cai ở nghĩa ăn bỏ học,
dây nhà đi ra các tình phế bắt.
Theo tù tên từ công an Việt vì châu,
đất vị này vừa giúp đợi các gia đình.
Tìm được các chau, lời tay nữa ăn, lời tay hấp dế, lời hấp dế, lời hấp dế, lời tay nữa hắt,
chú tại sạch châu phòng, phạch vì châu về nhà ăn tòn.
Chức đó, sáng nay mình tạm thắng thắng mời,
xuất khi nghe theo xử dù dê,
lưu kéo của bắt này, không vừa là bốn châu cai đã bọn nhà đi để các tình phế bắt.
Vì đi, các chau để lại toàn bộ tiếp lịch linh lạc cục là thương khủy ra đi.
Lựa dung là đi làm kính tiền và nhắn ra điện không phải tình kiếm.
Hây xa đó, các xa điện đã để trình bỏ công an sáng,
công an hội để để bị được sức tớ.
Chỉ xo hai hay tiếp nhật thông tin từ ra điện,
đến hai nhà sẽ bằng buốt nhà thì một thắng mời,
sau bốn biết a tiền, xin này, đêm và các liện thấp liệu phụ
tổ công tác tệ tình được các chau tạc thình hỏa hả nằm.
Chúnga nhà thắng mời, sâu khi phối hợp với các cơ quan liên quan,
công an vệ truy cho đã cùng các xa điện chú ở xấu phòng.
Lên cơ quan công an vệ,
đặc viên và đón các chau về nhà ăn thuan.